I know Newman and they said Dean and I
couldn't be on the stage together again
ladies and gentlemen we would like you
to know that on the stage of this
evening the Pantages Theatre consists of
for the most part the celluloid colony
the people that put their heart and
souls into making motion pictures we
certainly appreciate the fact that you
are with us tonight to the viewing
audience we are indeed indebted you're
tuning in we are very very sorry about a
very very good friend Danny Thomas who
must have a three tonight in ratings and
here you see he's opposite this show on
another network and of course we are of
course very very indebted to a gentleman
who did a magnificent job and we would
like you to join us in thanking mr.
Lionel Newman in the orchestra ladies
and gentlemen
yeah happy to Susan and Susie said she's
happy too we would like to now do 300
courses of there's no business like show
business and we would certainly
appreciated you ladies and gentlemen
would not leave your seats immediately
because the manager of the theater wants
us to let you know that they are showing
a Three Stooges comedy to cheer up the
losers and for the benefit of all of you
ladies and gentlemen who have your cars
parked outside you wait you're giving me
time I see we would like for you to
please file out very very carefully
because we have some very valuable
property on the stage tonight mr Newman
may I take the baton and if I hit the
downbeat then they can sing and we can
walk off the audience can leave and
we'll have a test pattern for an hour in
20 minutes
I do all this please how are you thank
you very much
ladies and gentlemen may we take a
moment to recap some of the outstanding
awards given this evening the 31st
annual Academy Awards the Foreign
Language Film award was given to France
for the film my uncle for scoring of a
musical picture Gigi the award to Andre
Previn or costume design
the award was given to mr. Cecil Beaton
or Gigi
music score of a grammatical comedy
picture the winner of the award was
Nicky kyon-kun for the score of the old
man in the sea the award for art
direction and set decoration the award
to Gigi for art mr. William a Horning
mr. Preston aims and for set decoration
mr. Henry grace and he'll Gleeson
the award for black-and-white
cinematography went to mr. Sam Levitt
for the Defiant one for color
cinematography mr. Joseph Gutenberg was
the incipient 4gg and the special Irving
G Thalberg memorial award was given this
year to mr. Jack L Warner the winner of
the award of Supporting Actress was
Wendy Hiller in separate tables or
supporting actor mr. burr lives in the
big country the best song of the year
GG music by Frederick Loewe lyrics by
alan jay lerner for writing best
screenplay GG alan jay lerner for
directing GG again mr. bin sandy Minelli
the best actress of the year miss Susan
Hayward for I want to live and the best
actor of the year mr. David Niven in
separate tables and finally the best
picture of the year GG winner of nine
Awards this evening Arthur freed
producer